Argentina is an interesting case.
Busy at the end of the 19th century.
It was the richest country on the planet
that is,
it was Richard than the United States,
Australia,
Canada,
and the United Kingdom.
Even when it was at the peak of the
British empire,
[inaudible]
middle of the 20th century,
the country had already gone down a few
positions,
but it still remains one of the 10
richest and most prosperous countries in
the world today.
However,
it's not even in the top 60 so how can a
country suffer such a dramatic decline?
Well,
it might have something to do with the
fact that since roughly speaking,
the 1940s Argentina has known only to
political movements,
military and Peronas.
Yeah,
yeah.
Previous video here on the visual
politic,
we talked about the origins of Coronas,
and we saw how Juan Domingo Peron came
to power wash.
His political approach wasn't how in
1955 he was overthrown by a new coo to
tops.
So the question is,
well,
what happens after this key?
What happened to Argentina and how did
[inaudible] involve?
And perhaps most importantly,
what does it mean?
What is Peruna Islam Today?
Well,
listen,
up in 1955 there were two cute atars
against Quando Quango Peron's government
in the fast,
which proved unsuccessful.
The Argentine navy bombarded the Plaza
de Mayo in an attempt to,
to end the president's life.
Yup.
That
it's just a few months later in
September of 1955 it did not fail.
Yeah.
Got It.
You'd be [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
hello
to go into exile first in Venezuela,
then in Panama,
and then it's finally and Francisco
Franco,
Spain.
When the new government's arrived
proclaiming the liberating revolution,
brandism was literally outlawed
everything.
Absolutely.
Everything that had to do with the
[inaudible] image,
the marches,
the symbols that Hims,
the names,
everything was prohibited by the
military government.
No.
I then feed off and even said,
Addis [inaudible] America.
[inaudible] is your list.
Okay.
In just two years,
this liberating revolution dismantled
every prunus structure.
Before having new elections,
they even changed the constitution
again,
so reestablish the one from 1853
although they did introduce 14 articles
which introduced almost all the social
and interventionists measures that Peron
had established.
Okay.
The truth is that history is hard to
forget.
It's by forbidding everything that had
to do with Peronas and in a way the
military governments turns him into a
kind of,
yeah.
The fact is that in the following
democratic elections in 1958 presidents
are,
Toro from DC was elected a politician
who tried to turn Argentina her rounds
and reopening it to the wells,
which is precisely what made the country
one of the richest in the world.
Hold on a moment because despite the
good economic results,
he had to face the peroneus unions and
the military.
I had of course already gotten used to
playing with Argentina,
however they wished because,
well,
once the military boots is used,
it's very hard to suppress the
temptation to use it again and again.
The fact is that a few years later,
the military demanded the resignation of
the democratic presidents from DC as
well.
Why did they do this?
Well,
simply because they felt like us.
I mean,
it's pretty much reason enough.
Ans when the president didn't accept
this,
well,
what do you think the Argentine military
did?
Well,
yes.
You probably guessed right.
They used weapons to depose and then
imprison him.
Yeah.
The fact is the little by little,
the atmosphere became increasingly tense
and Peroneus themselves while mobilizing
more and more demanding Peron's return.
There were elections and they are very
fragile.
Our governments.
What was the result of this?
The military made another cute to Ravi
this time.
They gave it a rather poetic name.
In this case they called us the origins
Hein Revolution led by the guy your
seeing here.
That's a general Juan Carlos
[inaudible].
Why?
And this was the beginning of very tense
period because in addition to the
dictatorship,
the cold war was going on.
Man's in Latin America.
That generally meant struggles between
leftist guerrillas and military
governments,
Argentina,
they were no exception.
I think we and we can
save it in the 1960s seventies and
eighties work terrible,
terrible years,
are pretty much all of Latin America and
the following year is gorilla and
terrorist groups began to emerge
throughout Argentina,
such as the Monta narrows,
he revolutionary people's army,
the people's armed forces,
and check this out because Peron himself
had taken his strategic turns to the
left and was now encouraging these types
of movements or from his home in Madrid,
which of course was located in Puerta to
Herro,
one of the most expensive areas of the
Spanish capital.
The fact is that between the bad
economic situation and the attacks,
that was such huge amount of discontent
for the military regime was forced to
call for elections in March of 1973
although they of course left per on out
under the excuse that he didn't live in
Argentina bugs.
That's ultimately did it matter.
And September of 1973 new elections were
held cannes.
This time Juan Domingo Peron was elected
presidents with check this out,
his wife Isabel Martinez dip around as
vice president.
Yes.
It was simply easier that way.
Everything stayed in the family,
the president and vice president,
the tandem one,
them an overwhelming victory with
approximately 60% of the vote.
But hold on a moment because it wouldn't
be that easy.
Listen up the return.
One thing needs to be clear if that is
an unwritten law.
In politics,
opposition is one thing and governments
are very different one and that law
certainly applied to quantum domingo
or on
see as we mentioned before,
during his time in exile,
he became a point of reference for every
opponent of the dictatorship.
But if on the left and on the rise,
but of course this friendship between
the extremes once the dictatorship fell
was doomed to fall not long after,
and that the viewer is precisely what
happens.
And in a very violent,
the situation got out of hands.
The leftist guerrilla groups continue to
attack.
Civilians,
politicians,
businessmen,
as well as the military per on was no
longer enough.
They once it's a popular revolution,
well at least that's what they called
it.
And if we're in this government
responded by promoting the creation.
Listen to this,
have a para military group known as the
triple aim anticommunist Argentinian
association.
The results of all of this mixed was
tension there,
confrontations and disappearances,
and if that wasn't enough,
the economy also ends from bat much
worse.
So problems were done.
It was becoming a bit of a nes,
and it didn't last very long because on
July,
the first 1974 funds and being gay per
on his days,
they came to an end and he left behind a
terrible legacy.
In 1975 the war between Peronas,
it's under a proneness to government,
was at its peak,
and it's the economic crisis led to a
brutal devaluation that left the peso in
tatters.
With this panorama,
you can probably imagine followed a new
queue to tar,
and it was not just by anyone.
The darkest periods in Argentine history
began on March the 24th 1976 the
military junta government rose to power
leds by Jorge Rafaelle of the dealer
who's period leading Argentina was
characterized by the permanent
violations of individual rights.
Cool.
We've got got,
he'd pick up when,
I mean that I've had that board about
patio there.
The military left behind terrible
numbers.
More than 10,000
disappeared and thousands and thousands
more became political prisoners.
But did you have just a moment here
because if you think ism was dead at
this time,
well you're very,
very wrong.
A new ride.
Yes.
After the dark and terrible periods of
the military junta democracy returned to
Argentina in 1983
five
at that time the brain is sweat
dismantled and a new president was
elected,
Raul Alfonsin who the elgin dines most
remember for the hyperinflation that
occurred under his rule.
Oh trust me,
don't thank God.
And I said,
what do you got?
Inflation soared to over 80% per month,
which is pretty much what happens when
you just run the money printing
machines.
And on top of that,
both the military again and the Peroneus
do unions decided to make this
government inoperable?
The strikes were absolutely endless.
So once they were reorganized,
you know,
what's the Peroneus returns this time
under the leadership of Carlos Soul men
m and surprise,
the new president's off to two terrible
first years,
took a 180 degree turn and to knowledge
to policies that were completely
unexpected for a peroneus governments.
He brought a wave of privatizations,
liberalized the economy and trade and
even achieved a monetary stability by
introducing the ones a one peso US
dollar exchange rate.
Martin investments began to arrive,
trade grew,
and as the Arjun tines where again
prospering and feeling like they could
rise up in the world again,
bars and my friend's president,
Menem did not do one thing and it's
president macri take note here because
he did not reduce public spending on the
country.
Public spending absolutely skyrocketed
and so did corruption and waste of all
varieties.
I'm awesome.
More since things were going smoothly,
the reforms,
they won't complete it.
Even Argentina with an overvalued
currency,
a huge public expenditure,
many imports and a ton of debt
and you can probably guess what happened
is in 1999 the opposition took over.
It was too late.
The crisis peaked in 2001 Argentina
defaulted and the origin Argentines
suffered.
The famous Cora Alito under this
situation in 2003 you gas disc corona
returned to power.
The brutus disability to wriggle out of
the line of falls into blame.
Others.
It's actually pretty admirable.
They've almost always been in
government,
but apparently they've never been to
blame for anything.
Do you know who came to power here?
Yes.
It would be the Coachnas proneness who
has the same policies as always.
Only this time,
very much more inclined to the left.
Remember,
during the years and the Casa Rosada,
the Argentine Whitehouse,
could they restricted imports,
multiplied public spending,
inflation taxes and debt boss?
Give you just a moment because before we
finish the video today,
we have one last question.
It's a really important,
what
spout on Islam,
what is Peronas it?
How is it managed to be almost hegemonic
in Argentina despite the fact that it
sounded terrible results?
These are the truly important questions.
Well,
the viewer,
I think that taking history into
accounts,
we can say the personas in more than a
political party is a movements with two
essential pillars,
excessive interventionism and public
spending.
Amen.
The secrets of their political success
has to do with this.
Every time Argentina has a problem,
the Peroneus promised more and more
public spending all of course financed
with the populist politicians favorite
instrument,
the bill printing machine under the
excuse of political sovereignty,
economic independence,
and social justice.
The three faces established by Juan
Domingo Peron Peronas have ended up in
making Argentina a country that is close
to the wells that has longterm monstrous
inflation and practically lives in
permanent crisis.
So the question really becomes,
isn't it?
Perhaps time to find another way.
So now it's your turn from one to five.
What is your degree of confidence in
Argentina is future?
You can leave your answer in the
comments below as well as in this a
vacant,
I really hope you enjoyed this video.
Please do.
Like if he did and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for brand new
videos.
Also,
don't forget to check it.
Our friends at reconsider media.
They provided vocals in this episode,
but why not mine?
And as always,
thank you for watching.
[inaudible].